i want to talk about taika's new movie
uh next goal wins which is obviously
we're
huge taika fans and i know you are too
yeah this is this is a completely
different movie than i think people are
expecting
um can you tell people what it's about
and also what was it like
having him on set directing um i mean
he's
so talented so talented i mean he's he's
he's
he's phenomenally talented he's almost
too talented for his own good
uh but he it it's the story of
a coach played by played hilariously and
perfectly by michael fassbender
who goes to kind of like as a dead-end
job just to kind of get rid of them they
send him down to american samoa to go
coach a soccer team there and it's about
what happens to this coach when he goes
down to samoa to coach a soccer team
um it's it's hilarious and it's fun and
it's heartfelt and there are things in
it that are really touching and
uh like like all of tyco's films i mean
like hunt for the wilder people
like you know i mean that that movie is
funny and touching and you'll cry and
laugh in the same film and like that's
very taika you know i mean when he wants
to do that that's what he's gonna do
uh having him on set is the best you
know when he's when he's not sleeping
that is
um but uh uh
actually his his napping thing is is
also
very impressive he's got this thing
where he'll go okay set up this camera
over there send it out over there
instead of that over there how long will
that be and they'll be like uh that'll
be about three minutes and he'll go
great and then he'll be
out and then two minutes and 55 seconds
later he'll go
okay are the cameras ready and he was
like what was that like holy [ __ ] man
um but he also his brain
works better than everyone else's so
when the whole point of the script or
i'm sorry when the whole point of the
film was
a lot of improvisation he would be there
with you go okay now now
go go go down that line this now talk
about this okay now talk about that now
say this now say that you know i mean
he's right there
helping you and coaching you through
this whole thing and it just makes you
feel really safe and really protected
and
yeah i mean he's a lot of fun to work
with